so you have described Drax as possibly
the happiest guardian at the start of
this film tell me about that yeah I
think so I think it's just because I
think Drax is young found in a new
family you know I think he's uh he's
learning to live in love again because
at this moment he's pretty content we're
more content than he's been in a long
long look out oh I tried guys so
attractive version of loving maybe a
little bit different and everyone yeah
oh oh where is he a different
perspective on things he's not aware and
he's off often you know confused but I
think that's you know therein lies the
real exploit drinks see you saw everyone
your deepest darkest secret dude come on
you're overreacting a little
you must be so advanced haha Jax is
laughs amazing was that something that
you and James work together on like
heaven no there was a change going
laughs louder not bigger laughs louder
and James wanted Drax to be in the
background laughing and I started
laughing and then he just asked me to
just I was laughing hahaha and then it
just got really like overbearingly like
weird shockingly loud and that's why you
get the true reactions of people going
because it was just so laughs we learn a
lot more about Drax this time around how
much of that did you know in the first
movie or was that new information we had
talked more about Jax's past and scenes
that we actually shot that were cut out
just wasn't room to tell more of his
story but yeah I was very familiar with
his background his past and the story of
his family well right now like I'm super
happy with
I think there's a there's enough and
people know enough pleasure actually
embracing them maybe her
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]